From PRI, Public Radio International. From PRI, Public Radio. From PRI, Public Radio. Public Radio. Public Radio International.
来自PRI，国际公共广播电台。来自PRI，公共广播。来自PRI，公共广播。公共广播。国际公共广播电台。
I was talking to a first-grader about libraries, and I suddenly found myself talking about bullies. That's the thing about the idea of the bullies, the idea is so powerful that it can derail any conversation and pull it towards its own orbit. Here's how it happened. We were on a school bus. I was asking the first-grader what kinds of books he takes out from the library, and that was all it took. Suddenly he launches into this big thing.
我当时正和一个一年级学生谈论图书馆，突然发现自己开始谈论校园霸凌了。这就是校园霸凌这个概念的特别之处，它的概念非常强大，足以让任何对话脱轨，并将其拉入自己的轨道。事情是这样的。我们当时在校车上。我问那个一年级学生他从图书馆借什么书，就因为这句话。突然，他滔滔不绝地说开了。
This kid in our class, he's a bully, and he takes out bully books. He takes out bully ones.
我们班有个孩子，他是恶霸，他借那种霸凌书。他借霸凌题材的书。
Like what are the bully books?
比如什么是霸凌书？
They teach you how to be meaner, to push people around and stuff.
它们教你怎么变得更刻薄，去欺负人什么的。
There are books to teach you how to be mean?
还有教你怎么变刻薄的书？
Yeah. And nice. There's this one book that's called, bully, bully's are made for pushing around, and bullies make all the rules, and they be picking on nice kids.
是的。还有变友善的书。有一本书叫《恶霸》，上面说恶霸就是为了欺负人而生的，恶霸制定所有规则，他们专门欺负好孩子。
As far as I was able to determine later, talking with parents and teachers and consulting with books in print, there is no book. There is no real book that corresponds to the book this first-grader thinks he saw the bully read. And you know, it's a shame. It was such a comforting thought. Why are people bullies? Why are they so mean? Why do they push you sometimes, and take your change, and say nasty things? Maybe they're just getting it from a book.
据我后来向家长、老师询问以及查询出版书籍目录得知，根本没有这本书。并没有一本真正的书对应这个一年级学生认为他看到的那个恶霸读的书。你知道，这真遗憾。那真是一个令人安慰的想法。为什么有人会成为恶霸？为什么他们那么刻薄？为什么他们有时会推搡你，抢你的零钱，说些难听的话？也许他们只是从书里学来的。
I'm surprised. Are you sure that that's what the book was about? I can't believe somebody would write a book saying, here's how to be mean to other people.
我很惊讶。你确定那本书是关于这个的吗？我不敢相信会有人写一本书，专门教人怎么去欺负别人。
Well, maybe the person who wrote it was probably a bully himself.
嗯，也许写这本书的人自己可能就是个恶霸。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Back for another week documenting stories of these United States using all the tools of radio storytelling-- documentaries, monologues, overheard conversations, found tapes, anything we can think of.
这里是WBEZ芝加哥电台，《美国生活》节目。我是艾拉·格拉斯。又一周的时间，我们将用广播讲故事的所有工具——纪录片、独白、偶然听到的对话、现成的录音带，以及任何我们能想到的东西，来记录这些美国的故事。
And today we bring you three stories about the cruelty of children. Act one, writer David Sedaris explains why he made fun of sissy boys when he was one himself. Act two, children and a man trapped in a well. And act three, well, just stay with us and listen.
今天我们带来三个关于儿童残忍行为的故事。第一幕，作家大卫·塞达里斯解释了他自己小时候为什么会取笑那些娘娘腔的男孩。第二幕，孩子们和一个被困在井里的男人。第三幕，好吧，留下来听听就知道了。
Act one. David Sedaris is a regular contributor to our program. His latest book is Dress Your Family in Corduroy and Denim. And this next story was recorded a few years ago at a fundraiser for the program Stories on Stage here in Chicago. In this story, David Sedaris describes a web of meanness which he participates in, as a victim sometimes, and as a perpetrator sometimes. Quick warning-- some moments in the story might not be suitable for younger listeners.
第一幕。大卫·塞达里斯是我们节目的常客。他的最新书是《给你的家人穿上灯芯绒和牛仔布》。接下来的这个故事是几年前在芝加哥“舞台故事”节目的筹款活动上录制的。在这个故事中，大卫·塞达里斯描述了一个他参与其中的刻薄网络，有时作为受害者，有时作为施害者。简短警告——故事中有些片段可能不适合年幼的听众。
These are things I'm working on for a new book, a collection of nonfiction stories. When asked if they're true, I prefer to answer that they're true enough. The only thing you'll need to know in terms of this first story is that during the seventh and eighth grade, I normally spent my summers working at Dorothea Dix, a state mental hospital, and that by law, every homosexual must at some point write a variation of this exact story-- "I Like Guys."
这些是我正在为一本新书准备的内容，是一部非虚构故事集。当被问及这些故事是否真实时，我更喜欢回答说它们“足够真实”。对于第一个故事，你只需要知道，在七年级和八年级期间，我通常会在暑假期间在州立精神病院多萝西娅·迪克斯工作，而且法律规定，每个同性恋者在某个时候都必须写出一个完全相同的故事变体——“我喜欢男生”。
Shortly before graduating the eighth grade, it was announced that, come fall, our county school system would adopt a policy of integration by way of forced busing. My Spanish teacher broke the news in a way she hoped might lead us to a greater understanding of her beauty and generosity.
在八年级毕业前不久，学校宣布秋季起，我们县的校区将采取强制校车接送的方式来实现种族融合。我的西班牙语老师宣布这一消息的方式，是希望我们能借此更深地了解她的美貌和慷慨。
"I remember the time I was at the state fair, standing in line for a snow cone," she said, fingering the kiss curls that trained her squat, compact face. "And a little colored girl ran up and tugged at my skirt, asking if she could touch my hair, 'Just once,' she said, 'just one time for luck.' Now, I don't know about the rest of you, but my hair means a lot to me."
“我记得有一次在州博览会上，排队买雪泥的时候，”她一边说着，一边用手指拨弄着她那矮小紧凑脸庞上卷曲的鬓角。“一个小黑人女孩跑过来拉住我的裙子，问她能不能摸摸我的头发，‘就一次，’她说，‘就摸一次沾沾好运。’好吧，我不知道你们其他人怎么想，但我的头发对我来说意义重大。”
The members of my class nodded to signify that their hair meant a lot to them, as well. They inched forward in their seats, wondering where this story might be going. Perhaps the little girl was holding a concealed razor blade. Maybe she was one of the troublemakers out for fresh white scalp. I sat marveling at their naivete. Like all her other antidotes, this woman's story was headed straight up her ass.
班上的同学点头表示他们的头发对他们来说也很重要。他们坐在座位上向前挪动，想知道这个故事会往哪里发展。也许那个小女孩手里藏着剃须刀片。也许她是那些出来寻找鲜活白人头皮的捣乱分子之一。我坐着，惊叹于他们的天真。就像她所有的轶事一样，这个女人的故事最后都显得荒唐至极。
"I checked to make sure she didn't have any candy on her hands, and then I bent down and let this colored girl touch my hair." The teacher's eyes assumed that dewy, faraway look she reserved for such Hallmark moments. "Then this little fudge colored child put her hand on my cheek and said, 'Oh,' she said, 'I wish I could be white and pretty like you.'"
“我检查了一下，确定她手上没有糖果，然后我弯下腰，让这个黑人女孩摸了摸我的头发。”老师的眼睛露出了那种她专门为这种感人时刻准备的朦胧、遥远的神情。“然后这个小软糖颜色的孩子把手放在我的脸颊上说，‘噢，’她说，‘我真希望我也能像你一样又白又漂亮。’”
She paused, positioning herself on the edge of the desk as though she were posing for a portrait the government might use on a stamp commemorating gallantry. "The thing to remember," she said, "is that more than anything in the world these people wish they were white."
她停顿了一下，坐在书桌边缘，仿佛在为政府可能印在纪念英勇精神邮票上的画像摆姿势。“要记住的事情，”她说，“是他们最渴望的莫过于成为白人。”
I just wasn't buying it. This was the same teacher who, when announcing her pregnancy, said, "I just pray my first baby is a boy. I'll have a boy, and then, maybe later, I'll have a girl, because if you do it the other way around, there's a good chance the boy will turn out to be funny."
我根本不买账。就是这个老师，在宣布她怀孕时说：“我只祈求我的第一个孩子是个男孩。我会生个男孩，然后以后再要个女孩，因为如果你反过来做，很有可能那个男孩会变得‘娘娘腔’（funny）。”
"Funny as in having no arms and legs?" I asked.
“娘娘腔是指没有胳膊和腿吗？”我问。
"That," the teacher said, "is far from funny. That is tragic. And you, sir, should have your lips sewn shut for saying such an ugly thing. When I say funny I mean funny as in," she relaxed her wrist, allowing her hand to dangle and flop, "I mean funny as in that kind of funny." She minced across the room, but it failed to illustrate her point, as this was her natural walk. A series of gambling little steps, her back held straight, giving the illusion she was balancing something of value atop her empty head.
“那个，”老师说，“那远不是娘娘腔。那是悲剧。而你，先生，你应该因为说了这么丑陋的话而被缝上嘴唇。当我说的‘娘娘腔’是指，”她放松手腕，让手悬空摇晃，“我是指那种‘娘娘腔’。”她在房间里迈着碎步走来走去，但这并没有说明她的观点，因为这是她自然的步态。一连串轻盈的小碎步，背挺得笔直，给人一种她在空空的脑袋上顶着什么贵重物品的错觉。
My math teacher did a much better version. A former coach, he accompanied his routine with a high pitched lisp, snatching a purse off the back of a student's chair, he pranced about the room, batting his eyes and blowing kisses at the boys seated on the front row. [? "'Tho 'fery nice to meet you," he'd say. Not wanting to draw any attention to myself, I hooted and squawked along with the rest of the class, all the while thinking, that's me he's talking about.
我的数学老师做了一个更好的版本。他曾是教练，他用一种尖细的口吻配合着他的表演，从学生的椅子背上抢走钱包，他在房间里跳来跳去，扇动着眼睛，向坐在前排的男生吹吻。“真是太高兴见到你们了，”他说。我不想引起注意，便跟着全班同学一起起哄尖叫，心里却想，他说的那个就是我。
What really bothered me was that this was such an easy way to get a laugh. As entertainers, these teachers were nothing, zero, they could barely impersonate themselves. "Look at you," the coach would shout, skipping across the basketball court. "You're a group of ladies, a bunch of silly queers."
真正困扰我的是，这居然是一种如此容易获得笑声的方式。作为表演者，这些老师什么都不是，零分，他们几乎无法模仿自己。“看看你们，”教练会尖叫着，在篮球场上跳跃。“你们是一群淑女，一群愚蠢的同性恋。”
I had never done anything with another guy, and literally prayed it would never happen. As much as I fantasized about it, I understood that there could be nothing worse than that. You'd see them on television from time to time, the homosexuals, maybe on one of the afternoon talk programs or filling in as a contestant on one of the game shows. They were the celebrities never asked about their home life, the men running a scarf under their toupee or framing their face with their open palms in an attempt to eliminate the circles beneath their eyes. "The poor man's face lift," my mother called it.
我从未和其他男人做过任何事，并确实祈祷永远不要发生。尽管我对此充满了幻想，但我明白没有什么比这更糟的了。你时不时会在电视上看到他们，那些同性恋者，也许是在某个下午的谈话节目中，或者是作为游戏节目的参赛者。他们是那些从不被问及家庭生活的名人，那些在假发下塞着围巾，或者用张开的手掌框住脸以消除眼下黑眼圈的男人。“穷人的拉皮手术，”我母亲称之为。
Regardless of their natty attire, they were always sweaty and desperate, willing to play the fool in exchange for the studio applause they seemed to mistake for love and acceptance. I saw something of myself in their mock weary delivery and the way they crossed their legs and laughed at their own jokes.
无论他们的穿着多么时髦，他们总是出汗且绝望，愿意为了换取他们似乎误认为是爱和接纳的现场掌声而扮演傻瓜。我在他们那种伪装的疲惫谈吐以及他们交叉双腿嘲笑自己笑话的方式中看到了自己的影子。
I pictured their homes, the finicky placement of their throw rugs and sectional sofas, the magazines carefully fanned just so upon the coffee table, with no wives or children to disturb their order. I imagined the pornography hidden in their closets and envisioned them powerless and sobbing as the police led them away in shackles, past the teenage boy who stood bathed in the light of the television news camera, shouting, "That's him. He's the one who touched my hair."
我幻想着他们的家，那些挑剔摆放的地毯和组合沙发，咖啡桌上精心扇形摆放的杂志，没有妻子或孩子来打扰他们的秩序。我幻想着藏在壁橱里的色情读物，想象着当警察用手铐把他们带走，经过站在电视新闻摄影机灯光下尖叫着“就是他。就是他摸了我的头发”的十几岁男孩时，他们那种无助和哭泣的样子。
It was my plan to win a contest, cash in my prizes, and use the money to visit a psychiatrist who might cure me of having homosexual thoughts. I would tell my family I'd given the money to charity, and then, under the doctor's supervision, I would really buckle down and change. I swore I would.
我的计划是赢得比赛，兑现奖金，并用这笔钱去看一位可能治愈我同性恋思想的精神病医生。我会告诉家人我把钱捐给了慈善机构，然后在医生的监督下，我真的会痛改前非。我发誓我会的。
My parents knew a couple whose son had killed a minister while driving drunk. They had friends whose oldest daughter had sprinkled a bundt cake with Comet, and once vacationed with a man whose children had set fire to the family's elderly border collie. Yet they spoke of no one whose son was a homosexual. The odds struck me as bizarre, but the message was the same. This was clearly the worst thing that could happen to a person.
我的父母认识一对夫妇，他们的儿子酒驾撞死了一位牧师。他们有朋友的大女儿在邦特蛋糕上撒了洗洁精，还曾和一个孩子放火烧了家里年老边境牧羊犬的男人一起度假。然而，他们没有提到任何人的儿子是同性恋。这种几率让我觉得很奇怪，但传达的信息是一样的。这显然是一个人可能发生的最糟糕的事情。
I washed my hands until they were pink and wrinkled, and then, deciding that clean hands were a sure giveaway, I dug my fingers into my mother's planter in order to pack dirt beneath my nails. The day to day anxiety was bad enough without my instructors taking their feeble little potshots. If my math teacher were able to subtract the alcohol from his diet, he'd still be on the football field where he belonged, and my Spanish teacher's credentials were based on nothing more than a long weekend in Tijuana as far as I was concerned.
我洗手洗到手变得粉红且起皱，然后，觉得干净的手肯定会暴露身份，我就把手指插进母亲的花盆里，在指甲底下填满泥土。日常的焦虑已经够糟糕了，更不用说我的老师们还在进行他们那软弱无力的小攻击。如果我的数学老师能从饮食中戒掉酒精，他本可以待在他所属的足球场上，而至于我的西班牙语老师，据我所知，她的资历不过是基于在蒂华纳度过的一个漫长周末。
Except for a few transfer students, I'd known most of the homosexuals since third grade. We'd spent years gathered together in cinder block offices as one speech therapist after another tried curing us of our lisps. Had there been a walking specialist, we would have met there, too. These were the same boys who avoided the shortcut through the woods and were the first to raise their hands when the teacher asked for a volunteer to read aloud from The Yearling or Lord of the Flies.
除了几个转校生，从三年级起我就认识大多数同性恋者了。多年来，我们聚在水泥砖块砌成的办公室里，听着一个又一个言语治疗师试图治好我们的口吃。如果有一个走路姿势矫正专家，我们也会在那里碰面。这些就是那些避开林间小路，并在老师征求朗读《小鹿斑比》或《蝇王》的志愿者时总是第一个举手的男孩。
We had long ago identified one another and understood that, because of everything we had in common, we could never be friends. To socialize would have drawn too much attention to ourselves. We were members of a secret society based upon self-loathing. When a teacher or a classmate made fun of a real homosexual, I made certain my laugh was louder than anyone else's. When a society member's clothing was thrown into the locker room toilet, I was always the first to cheer. When it was my clothing, I watched as the faces of my fellows broke into recognizable expressions of relief. They had been spared, and now it was someone else's turn.
我们很久以前就认出了彼此，并明白因为我们有这么多共同点，我们永远不可能成为朋友。社交会引来太多的关注。我们是一个基于自我厌恶的秘密社团的成员。当老师或同学嘲笑一个真正的同性恋时，我确保我的笑声比任何人都大。当一个社团成员的衣服被扔进更衣室的马桶时，我总是第一个欢呼的人。当轮到我的衣服时，我看着同伴们的脸上露出了明显的解脱表情。他们幸免于难，现在轮到别人了。
Several of my teachers, when discussing the upcoming school integration, would scratch at the damp stains beneath their arms, pulling back their lips to display every bit of tooth and gum. They made monkey noises, a manic succession of oohs and aahs I imagined they practiced nightly in their bedrooms. If an ape were seated in the room, I guess he might have identified their's as a cry of panic.
我的几位老师在讨论即将到来的学校种族融合时，会抓挠腋下的潮湿污渍，向后拉扯嘴唇，露出每一颗牙齿和牙龈。他们发出像猴子一样的声音，一种我猜想他们每晚在卧室里练习的狂躁的“噢”和“啊”的连续声。如果房间里坐着一只猿猴，我想它可能会把那识别为惊慌的尖叫。
Anything that caused them suffering brought me joy, but I doubted they would talk this way come fall. From everything I've seen on television, the negroes would never settle for such foolishness. As a people, they seemed to stick together, waving their fists against the backdrop of a fiery sky. They knew how to fight, and I hoped that, once they arrived, the battle might come down to black and white, leaving the rest of us alone.
任何导致他们痛苦的事情都会给我带来快乐，但我怀疑到了秋天他们还会这样说话。根据我在电视上所看到的一切，黑人绝不会容忍这种愚蠢行为。作为一个民族，他们似乎团结在一起，在火红的天空背景下挥舞着拳头。他们知道如何战斗，我希望一旦他们到来，这场战斗会变成黑人与白人之间的事，让其余的人独自待着。
At the end of the school year, my sister Lisa and I were excused from our volunteer jobs and sent to Greece to attend a month long summer camp advertised as the crown jewel of the Ionian Sea. The camp was reserved exclusively for Greek Americans, and featured instruction in such topics as folk dancing and religious training. I detested the idea of summer camp, but wanted to boast that I'd been to Europe. "It changes people," our neighbor had said, marking her garden with a series of tissue sized international flags. "Europe is the best thing that can happen to a person, especially if you like wine."
学年结束时，我和妹妹丽莎免去了志愿工作，被送到希腊参加为期一个月的夏令营，广告宣传称那是爱奥尼亚海上的明珠。该营地专门为希腊裔美国人预留，提供民间舞蹈和宗教训练等课程。我讨厌夏令营的想法，但想吹嘘自己去过欧洲。“它改变人，”我们的邻居曾说，并用一系列手帕大小的各国国旗标记她的花园。“欧洲是发生在一个人的身上最好的事情，尤其是如果你喜欢喝酒。”
I saw Europe as an opportunity to reinvent myself. I might still look and speak the same way, but having walked those ancient cobblestone streets, I would be identified as continental. "He has a passport," my classmates would whisper. "Quick, let's run before he judges us."
我把欧洲视为重塑自己的机会。我的外貌和说话方式可能依然一样，但走过那些古老的鹅卵石街道后，我会被视为具有欧洲风情。“他有护照，”同学们会低语。“快，我们跑吧，趁他还没评判我们。”
I told myself I would find a girlfriend in Greece. She would be a French tourist wandering the beach with a loaf of bread beneath her arm. Lisette would prove that I wasn't a homosexual, but a man with refined tastes. I pictured us holding hands against the silhouette of the Acropolis, her begging me to take a recording as a memento of our love.
我告诉自己，我会在希腊找个女朋友。她会是个漫步在海滩上，手臂下夹着一条面包的法国游客。莉塞特会证明我不是同性恋，而是一个有品位的男人。我幻想着我们在雅典卫城的剪影下牵手，她恳求我录下一段录音作为我们爱情的纪念。
"Silly you," I would say, brushing the tears from her eyes. "Just give me the beret, that'll be enough to hold you in my heart until the end of time." In case no one believed me, I would have my sister as a witness. Lisa and I weren't getting along very well, but hopefully the warm Mediterranean breezes might melt the icicle she seemed to have mistaken for a rectal thermometer.
“傻瓜，”我会说，擦去她眼中的泪水。“只要给我那个贝雷帽，这就足以让你在我的心中永远停留。”以防没人相信我，我会让妹妹作证。丽莎和我相处得并不好，但希望地中海温暖的微风能融化她那似乎被误认为是直肠温度计的冰块。
My father accompanied us to New York where we met our fellow campers for the charter flight. There were hundreds of them, each one confident and celebratory. They tossed their complimentary Aegean Airlines bags across the room, shouting and jostling one another. Were it an all girls camp, I would have been able to work up some enthusiasm, but spending a month in the company of boys, that was asking too much.
父亲陪我们去纽约，在那里我们遇见了搭乘包机同行露营的伙伴。有数百人，每个人都自信且欢庆。他们把爱琴海航空公司的免费包扔过房间，大声叫喊并互相推搡。如果这是个全女子露营，我本能积攒一些热情，但与一群男孩共度一个月，那要求实在太高了。
I tried to put it out of my mind, but faced with their boisterous presence, I found myself growing progressively more hysterical. My nervous tics shifted into their highest gear, and a crowd gathered, watching what they believed to be an epileptic seizure.
我试图把这事赶出脑海，但面对他们喧闹的存在，我发现自己逐渐变得越来越歇斯底里。我的神经抽动进入了最高档位，人群聚集起来，看着他们认为是癫痫发作的东西。
If my sister was anxious about the trip, she certainly didn't show it. Prying my fingers off her wrist, she crossed the room and introduced herself to a fellow camper. This was a tough looking Queens native named Stephanie Heartattackis or Testacokales. I recall only that her last name had granted her a lifelong supply of resentment. Stephanie wore mirrored aviator sunglasses and carried an oversize comb in the back pocket of her hip hugger jeans. Of all the girls in the room, she seemed the least likely candidate for my sister's friendship.
如果我妹妹对这次旅行感到焦虑，她肯定没表现出来。她从我的手腕上掰开我的手指，穿过房间向一位营友介绍自己。这是一个看起来很硬气的皇后区本地人，名叫斯蒂芬妮·心脏病发作（Heartattackis）还是特斯塔科卡莱斯（Testacokales）。我只记得她的姓氏给了她终生的怨恨。斯蒂芬妮戴着反光飞行员太阳镜，在低腰牛仔裤的后兜里塞着一把超大的梳子。在房间里所有的女孩中，她看起来最不可能成为我妹妹的朋友。
They sat beside one another on the plane, and by the time we disembarked in Athens, Lisa was speaking in a bad Queens accent. During the long flight, while I sat cowering beside a boy named Semen, my sister had undergone a complete physical and cultural transformation. Her shoulder length hair was now parted on the side, covering the left side of her face as if to conceal a nasty scar. She cursed and spat, scowling out the bus window as if she'd come to Greece with the sole intention of kicking its ass. "What a [BLEEP] hole," she yelled. "Jesus, if I'd known it was going to be this hot, I would have stayed home with my head in the oven, right goils?
她们在飞机上坐在一起，当我们抵达雅典时，丽莎已经用蹩脚的皇后区口音说话了。在漫长的飞行中，当我和一个叫西门（Semen）的男孩蜷缩在一起时，我妹妹已经完成了彻底的身体和文化改造。她齐肩长的头发现在从侧面分开，遮住了脸的左侧，仿佛是为了掩盖一个难看的伤疤。她咒骂并吐唾沫，像带着唯一目的就是要把希腊痛打一顿一样，气愤地盯着公共汽车窗外。“真是个[哔]地洞，”她尖叫道。“天哪，如果我早知道会这么热，我就待在家里，把头伸进烤箱了，对吧姑娘们？”
I approached her once we reached the camp, a cluster of whitewashed buildings hugging the desolate coast far from any neighboring village. "Listen [BLEEP] hole," she said, "as far as this place is concerned, I don't know you, and you sure as [BLEEP] don't know me. You got that?" "Hey, Carolina," one of her friends called. "All right, already," she brayed, "I'm coming, I'm coming." That was the last time we spoke until she borrowed money a week before returning home.
我们到达营地后我走近她，营地是一群白墙建筑，坐落在远离任何邻村的荒凉海岸上。“听着[哔]地洞，”她说，“至于这个地方，我不认识你，你当然也[哔]不认识我。懂了吗？”“嘿，卡罗莱纳，”她的一个朋友喊道。“好了，知道了，”她大叫道，“我来了，我来了。”那是我们最后一次交谈，直到她回国前一周借钱为止。
Lisa had adjusted with remarkable ease. Although we were cut from the same cloth, something deep in my stomach suggested I wouldn't do nearly so well. Camp lasted a month, during which time, I never once had a bowel movement. I was used to having a semi-private bathroom, and could not bring myself to occupy one of the men's room stalls, fearful that someone might recognize my shoes.
丽莎适应得非常轻松。虽然我们是同一块料，但我胃深处某种东西暗示我不会做得那么好。营地持续了一个月，在这期间，我一次都没有排便。我习惯了有半私人的浴室，无法强迫自己占用男厕所的隔间，生怕有人认出我的鞋子。
Sitting down three times a day for a heavy Greek meal became an exercise akin to packing a musket. I told myself I'd sneak off during one of our field trips, but those toilets were nothing more than a hole in the ground, a hole I could have easily filled with no problem whatsoever. I considered using the Ionian Sea, but for some unexplained reason, we were not allowed to swim in those waters.
每天三次坐下来吃一顿丰盛的希腊大餐变成了一种类似于装填火枪的练习。我告诉自己，我会趁实地考察时偷偷溜走，但那些厕所不过是地上的一个洞，一个我本可以轻松填满的洞，一点问题都没有。我考虑过使用爱奥尼亚海，但由于某种无法解释的原因，我们不被允许在那些水域游泳。
The camp had an Olympic size pool which was fed from the sea, and soon grew murky with stray bits of jelly fish, which had been pulverized by the pump. The tiny tentacles raised welts, so shortly after arriving, it was announced that we could photograph both the pool and the ocean, but we could swim in neither. The Greeks had invented democracy, built the acropolis, and then called it a day.
营地有一个奥林匹克规格的游泳池，是从海里取水的，很快就因被水泵粉碎的水母残骸而变得浑浊。微小的触须引起了红肿，所以刚到没多久，就宣布我们可以拍摄游泳池和海洋，但谁都不能游泳。希腊人发明了民主，建造了卫城，然后就收工了。
The camp was basically an extension of my junior high school, except here, everyone had either an excess of moles or a single eyebrow. The attractive, sports minded boys ran the show, currying favors from the staff and ruining the weekly outdoor movies with their inane heckling. From time to time, the rented tour buses would carry us to view one of the country's many splendors, and we would raid the gift shops, stealing anything that wasn't bolted down to the shelf. These were cheap plated puzzle rings and pint-size vases, little pom pom shoes and coffee mugs reading, "Sparta is for a lover."
营地基本上是我初中的延伸，只不过在这里，每个人要么有太多的痣，要么只有单眉毛。那些有吸引力、热爱运动的男孩控制着局面，讨好员工，并用他们愚蠢的嘲讽破坏了每周的户外电影。时不时地，租来的旅游巴士会载我们去参观这个国家的众多辉煌之地，我们会洗劫礼品店，偷走任何没有被锁在架子上的东西。这些都是廉价的电镀拼图戒指和小型花瓶，小绒球鞋和写着“斯巴达是给恋人的”咖啡杯。
My shoplifting experience was the only thing that gave me an edge over the popular boys. "Hold it like this," I whispered, "then swivel around and slip the statue of Diana down the back of your shorts, covering it with your t-shirt. Just remember to always back out the door, and never forget to wave goodbye."
我的行窃经验是唯一让我比受欢迎的男孩更有优势的地方。“像这样拿着，”我低声说，“然后转过身，把戴安娜雕像滑进短裤后面，用T恤盖住。只要记得始终倒着走出门口，别忘了挥手道别。”
There was one boy at camp I felt at ease with, a Detroit native named Pete who stepped on the bunk below me. Pete looked away while talking to the other boys, shifting his eyes as if he were studying the weather conditions. Like me, he used his free time to curl in a fetal position, staring at the bedside calendar upon which he'd exed out all the days he'd so far endured.
营地里有一个我感到自在的男孩，一个叫皮特的底特律本地人，他踩在我下铺上。皮特在和别的男孩说话时会看向别处，眼神游离，仿佛在研究天气状况。像我一样，他用业余时间蜷缩成胎儿姿势，盯着床头的日历，他在上面划掉了他所忍受过的所有日子。
We were finishing our 7:15 to 7:45 wash and rinse segment one morning, when the counselor arrived for inspection, shouting, "What are you, a bunch of goddamn faggots who can't make your goddamn beds?" I found myself giggling at his stupid choice of words, if any knew how to make their bed, it was a faggot. It was the others he needed to worry about.
有一天早上，我们刚完成7:15到7:45的洗漱冲洗环节，辅导员就赶来检查，大喊道：“你们是什么东西，一群不会铺床的该死娘娘腔吗？”我发现自己对他的愚蠢措辞咯咯发笑，如果说有人知道怎么铺床，那就是娘娘腔。他该担心的是其他人。
I caught Pete laughing, too, and soon, we took to mocking this counselor, referring to one another first as faggots, and then as stinking faggots. We were lazy faggots and sunburnt faggots before we eventually became faggoty faggots. We couldn't protest the word as it would have meant acknowledging the truth of it. The most we could do was embrace it as a joke, and in doing so, embody its darkest meaning, mincing and prancing about the room for each other's entertainment while the others weren't looking.
我发现皮特也在笑，很快，我们开始模仿这个辅导员，先是互相称对方为娘娘腔，然后是臭娘娘腔。我们是懒惰的娘娘腔和晒伤的娘娘腔，最终变成了娘娘腔中的娘娘腔。我们不能抗议这个词，因为那意味着承认它的真实性。我们最多只能把它作为玩笑来接受，这样做，反而体现了它最黑暗的含义，为了彼此的娱乐而在房间里扭动和蹦跳，趁别人不注意的时候。
Faggot as a word was always delivered in a harsh, unforgiving tone, befitting anyone weak or stupid enough to act upon their impulses. This was a game, less humiliating than soccer, but certainly more dangerous. Late at night, I'd feel my bunk buck and sway, knowing that Pete was either masturbating or beating eggs for an omelet. Is that me he's thinking about? Joining in, I would awake the next morning to find our entire iron framed unit had wandered a good foot away from the wall. Let the mountains stay where they were, our love had the power to move bunks.
“娘娘腔”这个词总是用一种严厉、不宽容的语气说出来，适合任何软弱或愚蠢到付诸行动的人。这是一种游戏，比足球没那么丢人，但肯定更危险。深夜，我会感觉到我的双层床摇晃和摆动，知道皮特要么在自慰，要么在为煎蛋卷搅拌鸡蛋。他在想我吗？我加入其中，第二天醒来发现我们整个铁框单元已经移动了一英尺远，离开了墙壁。让山留在原地吧，我们的爱有移动双层床的力量。
Having no willpower, we depended on circumstances to keep us apart. "This can't happen" was accompanied by the sound of bed springs whining, "Oh, but why can't it?" There came an afternoon when, running late for flag worship, we found ourselves alone in the cabin. What started off as name calling soon escalated to a series of mock angry slaps. We wrestled one another onto one of the lower bunks, knowing that these were not regulation holds, yet unable to stop ourselves.
因为没有意志力，我们依赖环境来保持距离。“这不能发生”伴随着床垫弹簧的哀鸣，“哦，但为什么不能呢？”有一个下午，因为去参加升旗仪式迟到了，我们发现自己独自在小屋里。起初的辱骂很快升级为一系列假装愤怒的掌掴。我们把对方摔倒在下铺的一张床上，明知这不是正规的擒拿，却无法停止自己。
"You kids think you invented sex," my mother was fond of saying. But hadn't we? With no written instruction manual or pre-scheduled rehearsal, didn't each of us come away feeling we had discovered something unspeakably modern? What produced in others a sense of swaggering exhilaration left Pete and I with a mortifying sense of guilt.
“你们这些孩子以为自己发明了性，”我母亲喜欢说。但难道不是吗？没有书面的指导手册或预先安排的排练，难道我们每个人不都觉得发现了某种不可言说的现代事物吗？别人感到狂妄的兴奋，而皮特和我留下的却是一种令人羞愧的负罪感。
We fled the room as if, in our fondlings, we had uncapped some virus we might still escape if we ran hard enough. Had one of the counselors not caught me scaling the fence, I was certain I would've made it back to Raleigh by morning, skittering across the surface of the water like one of those lizards often featured on the television wildlife specials.
我们逃离了房间，仿佛我们在爱抚中打开了某种病毒，只要跑得够快，我们或许还能逃脱。如果不是其中一名辅导员抓住我爬围栏，我确信我会在早上回到罗利，像电视野生动物节目中常见的那些蜥蜴一样，在水面上滑行。
When discovered making out with one of the Greek bus drivers, a 16 year-old camper was forced to stand beside the flag pole, dressed in long pants and thick sweaters. We watched her broil in the hot sun until, fully cooked, she stumbled for a moment or two before passing out. If this was a punishment for a boy and a girl, I could not begin to imagine the punishment they might level upon two boys.
当发现与一名希腊巴士司机调情时，一名16岁的营员被迫站在旗杆旁，穿着长裤和厚毛衣。我们看着她在烈日下烤炙，直到完全熟透，她在晕倒前踉跄了一两下。如果这就是对男孩和女孩的惩罚，我无法想象他们会给两个男孩什么样的惩罚。
Nothing, however, could match the cruelty and humiliation we soon practiced against one another. Pete started a rumor that I had stolen an athletic supporter from another camper and worshipped it as a keepsake. I retaliated, claiming that he had expressed a desire to become a dancer. "That's nothing," he said to the assembled crowd, "take a look at what I found on David's bed." He reached into the pocket of his shorts and withdrew a sheet of notebook paper upon which were written the words, "I like guys."
然而，没有什么能比得上我们不久后互相施加的残忍和羞辱。皮特散布谣言说我偷了另一个营员的护身符，并把它当作纪念品崇拜。我进行了报复，声称他曾表达过成为舞者的愿望。“那不算什么，”他对聚集的人群说，“看看我在大卫的床上发现了什么。”他伸手掏出短裤的口袋，抽出一张笔记本纸，上面写着：“我喜欢男生。”
Presented as an indictment, the document was both pathetic and comic. Would I supposedly have written a note to remind myself of that fact, least I forget? Had I intended to wear it taped to my bare back, advertising my preference next time our rented buses carried us off to yet another sun-drenched sexual playground? I like guys. He held the paper above his head, turning a slow circle so that everyone might get a chance to see it.
作为一项指控，这份文件既可悲又滑稽。难道我还会写一张纸条来提醒自己那个事实，以免我忘记吗？难道我打算把它贴在赤裸的背上，在我们租来的巴士下一次载我们去另一个阳光明媚的性游乐场时做广告吗？我喜欢男生。他把纸举过头顶，慢慢转了一圈，让每个人都有机会看到它。
I suppose he originally intended to plant it on my bunk for one of the counselors to find. Presenting it himself had foiled the note's intended effect. The other boys groaned and looked away, wondering why he'd picked it up and carried the thing around. He might as well have cradled a glistening turd, shouting, "Look what he did." Touching such a foul document made him suspect and guilty by association. In attempting to discredit one another, we round up alienating ourselves even further.
我猜他最初打算把它放在我的床上，让其中一名辅导员发现。他自己展示它反而抵消了纸条预期的效果。其他男孩发出呻吟并移开视线，想知道他为什么要把它捡起来带着到处走。他简直就像抱着一坨闪闪发光的屎，大喊：“看他做了什么。”触摸这样一份肮脏的文件让他变得可疑，并因此而有罪。在试图诋毁对方的过程中，我们最终更加疏远了自己。
During meals, I studied him from across the room. Clearly he had tricked me, cast a spell or slipped something into my food. I watched as he befriended a girl named Theodora and held her hand during a screening of A Lovely Way to Die, one of the cave paintings the camp offered as a weekly movie. She wasn't a bad person, Theodora. Someday, the doctors might find a way to transplant a calf's brain into a human skull, and she'd be just as lively and intelligent as he was. I tried to find a girlfriend of my own, but my one possible candidate was sent home after her leg brace got caught in the grill of a delivery truck.
用餐时，我从房间的另一头观察他。显然他欺骗了我，对我施了咒语或在我的食物里放了什么。我看着他与一个叫西奥多拉的女孩交朋友，并在放映《死法》（A Lovely Way to Die）时握住她的手，这是营地作为每周电影提供的壁画之一。她不是个坏人，西奥多拉。也许有一天，医生会找到一种将小牛大脑移植到人类头骨中的方法，她就会像他一样活泼聪明。我试着找一个自己的女朋友，但我的唯一候选人在她的腿部支架被卡进送货卡车的格栅后被送回了家。
Pete looked convincing enough in the company of his girlfriend. They scrambled up the steps of various ruins, snapping one another's pictures and sharing their private jokes, while I watched them, fuming. My jealousy stemmed from the belief that he had been cured. One fistful of my flesh, and he had lost all symptoms of the disease.
皮特在女朋友的陪伴下看起来很有说服力。他们爬上各种遗迹的台阶，互相拍照并分享私下的笑话，而我看着他们，怒火中烧。我的嫉妒源于一种信念，即他已经被治愈了。我的一把肉，他所有的疾病症状就消失了。
"We're thinking of getting married," I heard him boast to one of the other campers. "She lives in Florida, and I'm in Michigan, but if we wait a year, I'm pretty sure 16 is a legal age in Georgia." Yeah right, I thought. Legal age in Greece appeared to be about 12, why not just stay here, raise some goats, and start your own delivery service, you stupid, lying faggot.
“我们正考虑结婚，”我听到他向另一位营员吹嘘。“她住在佛罗里达，我在密歇根，但如果我们等一年，我肯定16岁在佐治亚州是法定年龄。”是的，我想。希腊的法定年龄似乎是12岁，为什么不留在这里，养几只山羊，开始你自己的快递业务呢，你这个愚蠢、说谎的娘娘腔。
Camp ended and I flew home with my legs crossed, dropping my bag of stolen souvenirs to race to the bathroom, where I spent the next several days sitting on the toilet and studying my face in a hand mirror. I like guys. The words had settled themselves into my features. I returned to my job at the mental hospital, carrying harsh Greek cigarettes I offered as incentives to some of the more difficult patients.
夏令营结束了，我交叉着双腿飞回家，扔下我那袋偷来的纪念品，冲进浴室，接下来的几天里我都坐在马桶上，用手镜观察自己的脸。我喜欢男生。这些词已经定格在我的五官中。我回到精神病院工作，带着刺鼻的希腊香烟，作为奖励提供给一些更难对付的病人。
"Faggot," one woman shouted, stooping to protect the collection of pine cones. "Get your faggoty hands away from my radio transmitters." "Don't mind her," the orderly said, "she's crazy." Maybe not, I thought, holding a pine cone up to my ear. She'd gotten the faggot part right, so maybe she was on to something.
“娘娘腔，”一个女人尖叫着，弯腰保护她的松果收藏。“把你那娘娘腔的手从我的无线电发射机上拿开。”“别理她，”护理员说，“她疯了。”也许不是，我想，把一个松果贴在耳边。她在娘娘腔那部分说对了，所以也许她发现了什么。
The moment we'd boarded our return flight from Kennedy to Raleigh, Lisa had rearranged her hair, dropped her accent, and turned to me, saying, "Well, I thought that was very nice. How about you?" Over the course of five minutes, she had eliminated all traces of her reckless European self. Why couldn't I do the same?
当我们登上从肯尼迪机场返回罗利的航班时，丽莎重新整理了头发，丢掉了口音，转向我说：“好吧，我觉得这很好。你觉得呢？”在五分钟内，她消除了她那鲁莽的欧洲自我的所有痕迹。为什么我不能也这样做呢？
Shortly before school began, I discovered that I would not be bused. There had been violence in other counties and states, troubles as far away as Boston, but in Raleigh the transition was peaceful. Not only the students, but many of the teachers had been shifted from one school to another. My new science teacher was a negro very adept at swishing his way across the room, mocking everyone from Albert Einstein to the dweebish host of a popular children's television program.
在开学前不久，我发现我不会被送去参加校车融合。其他县和州发生了暴力事件，甚至远至波士顿都有骚乱，但在罗利，这种转变是和平的。不仅是学生，许多老师也被从一所学校调到了另一所学校。我的新科学老师是一个黑人，他非常善于在教室里挥动着身体，嘲笑从阿尔伯特·爱因斯坦到流行儿童电视节目的呆头呆脑主持人的每个人。
Black and white, the teachers offered their ridicule as an olive branch. "Here," they said, "this is something we all have in common. Proof that we're all brothers under the skin." Thank you.
无论是黑人还是白人，老师们都把他们的嘲讽当作橄榄枝。“在这里，”他们说，“这是我们共同的东西。证明我们都是同肤色下的兄弟。”谢谢。
David Sedaris, reading years ago at a benefit for Stories on Stage. That story was later published in David's book Naked.
大卫·塞达里斯，多年前在“舞台故事”慈善活动上的朗读。那个故事后来发表在大卫的书《赤裸》中。
Coming up, kids decide not to save a man trapped in a well. Plus, an experiment that actually made kids less cruel. That's in a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，孩子们决定不去救一个困在井里的男人。还有一个实际上让孩子不那么残忍的实验。来自国际公共广播电台，我们的节目稍后继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program we choose a theme, invite a variety of writers and performers to take a whack at the theme. Today's theme is cruelty of children-- not cruelty to children, mind you, cruelty of children. And our next story is by writer Ira Sher. And in it, the children aren't cruel in a mean spirited or typical way, but the effect of their actions constitutes a kind of cruelty.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们都会在节目中选择一个主题，邀请各种作家和表演者来探讨这个主题。今天的主题是儿童的残忍——注意，不是对儿童的残忍，是儿童的残忍。我们的下一个故事由作家艾拉·谢尔创作。在故事中，孩子们并没有以一种恶意或典型的方式残忍，但他们行为的影响构成了一种残忍。
I was nine when I discovered the man in the well in an abandoned farm lot near my home. I was with a group of friends playing hide and go seek, or something, when I found the well, and then I heard the voice of the man in the well calling out for help.
我九岁时，在离家附近的一个废弃农场里发现了那个井里的男人。我和一群朋友在玩捉迷藏什么的，我发现了那口井，然后听到了那个男人在井里呼救的声音。
I think it's important that we decided not to help him. Everyone, like myself, was probably on the verge of fetching a rope, or asking where we could find a ladder, but then we looked around at each other, and it was decided. I don't remember if we told ourselves a reason why we couldn't help him, but we had decided then. Because of this, I never went very close to the lip of the well, or I only came up on my hands and knees, so that he couldn't see me.
我认为很重要的一点是，我们决定不去救他。每个人，像我一样，可能都曾处于去取绳子，或者问我们在哪里可以找到梯子的边缘，但随后我们互相环顾，就这么决定了。我不记得我们是否告诉过自己不能救他的理由，但当时我们就这么决定了。正因为如此，我从来没有靠近过井口，或者我只是跪着爬过来，这样他就看不见我。
And just as we wouldn't allow him to see us, I know that none of us ever saw the man in the well. The well was too dark for that, too deep, even when the sun was high up angling down the stone sides like golden hair. I remember that we were still full of games and laughter when we called down to him. He had heard us shouting while we were playing, and he had been hollering for us to come.
而且就像我们不会让他看见我们一样，我知道我们中间从来没有人见过那个井里的男人。井里太黑了，太深了，即使太阳高高挂起，像金色的头发一样斜射在石头边上。我记得当我们向他喊话时，我们仍然充满了游戏和笑声。他在玩耍时听到了我们的呼喊，他一直在大声叫我们要过去。
He was so relieved at that moment. "God, get me out. I've been here for days." He must've known we were children, because he immediately struggled us to go get a ladder, get help. At first afraid to disobey the voice from the man in the well, we turned around and actually began to walk toward the nearest house, which was Arthur's.
那一刻他感到如此宽慰。“天哪，快救我出去。我在这里待了好几天了。”他肯定知道我们是孩子，所以他立刻挣扎着让我们去拿梯子，寻求帮助。起初害怕违抗井里男人的声音，我们转过身，真的开始朝最近的房子走去，那是亚瑟家。
But along the way, we slowed down, and then we stopped. And after waiting what seemed like a good while, we quietly came back to the well. We stood or lay around the lip, listening for maybe half an hour. And then Arthur, after some hesitation, called down, "What's your name?" This, after all, seemed like the most natural question. The man answered back immediately. "Do you have the ladder?" We all looked at Arthur, and he called back down, "No, we couldn't find one."
但一路上，我们慢了下来，然后停了下来。在等待了似乎很长一段时间后，我们悄悄回到了井边。我们站在或躺在井口周围，听了大约半个小时。然后亚瑟，在犹豫之后，向下喊道：“你叫什么名字？”这毕竟似乎是最自然的问题。男人立刻回答。“你们有梯子吗？”我们都看着亚瑟，他向下喊道：“不，我们找不到。”
Now that we had established some sort of a dialogue, everyone had questions he or she wanted to ask the man in the well. The man wouldn't stop speaking. "Go tell your parents there's someone in this well. If they have a rope, or a ladder," he trailed off. His voice was raw, and sometimes he would cough. "Just tell your parents."
既然我们建立了一些对话，每个人都有想问井里那个男人的问题。男人不停地说话。“去告诉你们的父母，这口井里有人。如果他们有绳子或梯子，”他话音渐弱。他的声音沙哑，有时会咳嗽。“只要告诉你们的父母。”
We were quiet, but this time, no one stood up or moved. Someone, I think little Jason, called down, "Hello. Is it dark?" And then after a moment, "Can you see the sky?" He didn't answer, but instead told us to go again. When we were quiet for a bit, he called to see if we were gone. After a pause, Wendy crawled right to the edge so that her hair lifted slightly in the updraft. "Is there any water down there?"
我们保持安静，但这次，没有人站起来或走动。有人，我想是小杰森，向下喊道：“喂。那里面黑吗？”过了一会儿，“你能看见天空吗？”他没有回答，而是再次告诉我们去寻求帮助。当我们安静了一会儿，他大声叫喊，看我们是否离开了。停顿后，温蒂爬到边缘，头发在气流中微微抬起。“下面有水吗？”
"Have they gone for help?" He asked. She looked around at us, and then she called down, "Yes. They're all gone now. Isn't there any water down there?" I don't think anyone smiled at how easy it was to deceive him. This was too important. "Isn't there?" She said again.
“他们去寻求帮助了吗？”他问。她环顾我们，然后向下喊道：“是的。他们都走了。下面真的一点水都没有吗？”我不认为有人因为欺骗他如此容易而微笑。这太重要了。“真的没有吗？”她又说了一遍。
"No," he said. "It's very dry." He cleared his throat. "Do you think it will rain?" She stood up and took in the whole sky with her blue eyes, making sure. "No, I don't think so." We heard him cough in the well, and we waited for a while, thinking about him waiting in the well. Resting on the grass and cement by the well, I tried to picture him. I tried to imagine the gesture of his hand reaching to cover his mouth each time he coughed. Or perhaps he was too tired to make that gesture each time.
“没有，”他说。“非常干燥。”他清了清嗓子。“你觉得会下雨吗？”她站起来，用蓝色的眼睛扫视了整个天空，确保万无一失。“不，我想不会。”我们听到他在井里咳嗽，我们等了一会儿，想象着他待在井里的样子。我躺在井边的草地和水泥地上，试图描绘他。我试图想象他每次咳嗽时伸手捂住嘴的动作。或者也许他太累了，无法每次都做出那个动作。
After an hour, he began calling again, but for some reason, we didn't want to answer. We got up and began running, filling up with panic as we moved, until we were racing across the ruts of the old field. I kept turning, stumbling as I looked behind. Perhaps he had heard us getting up and running away from the well. Only Wendy stayed by the well for a while, watching us run as his calling grew louder and wilder, until finally she ran, too, and then we were far away.
一小时后，他开始再次呼喊，但出于某种原因，我们不想回答。我们起身开始奔跑，移动时心中充满恐慌，直到我们在旧田野的车辙上狂奔。我不断转身，笨拙地向后看。也许他听到了我们起身逃离井边的声音。只有温蒂在井边待了一会儿，看着我们奔跑，他的呼喊变得越来越大，越来越狂乱，直到最后她也跑了，然后我们跑得很远了。
The next morning, we came back, most of us carrying bread or fruit, or something to eat, in our pockets. Arthur brought a canvas bag from his house and a plastic jug of water. When we got to the well, we stood around quietly for a moment, listening for him. "Maybe he's asleep," Wendy said. We sat down around the mouth of the well on an old concrete slab, warming in the sun, and coursing with ants and tiny insects.
第二天早上，我们又回来了，大多数人兜里装着面包或水果或其他可以吃的东西。亚瑟从他家带来了一个帆布袋和一个塑料水罐。当我们到达井边时，我们安静地站了一会儿，听他的声音。“也许他睡着了，”温蒂说。我们坐在井口的一块旧水泥板上，在阳光下取暖，周围是蚂蚁和微小的昆虫。
Aaron called down then, when everyone was comfortable, and the man answered right away, as if he had been listening to us the whole time. "Did your parents get help?" Arthur kneeled at the edge of the well and called, "Watch out." And then he let the bag fall after holding it out for a moment, maybe for the man to see.
当大家都舒服了以后，亚伦向下喊了，男人立刻回答，仿佛他一直在听我们说话。“你们的父母去寻求帮助了吗？”亚瑟跪在井边喊道：“小心。”然后他把袋子放下去，在放下去之前停了一会儿，也许是为了让男人看到。
It hit the ground more quickly than I expected. That, combined with the feeling that he could hear everything we said, made him suddenly closer, as if he might be able to see us. I wanted to be very quiet so that if he heard or saw anyone, he would not notice me. The man in the well started coughing, and Arthur volunteered, "There's some water in the bag. We all brought something."
它落地的速度比我预期的要快。这与他能听到我们所说的一切的感觉结合在一起，使他突然变得更近了，仿佛他能看见我们一样。我想保持非常安静，这样如果他听到或看到任何人，他就不会注意到我。井里的男人开始咳嗽，亚瑟主动提议：“袋子里有一些水。我们都带了些东西。”
We could hear him moving around down there. After a few minutes he asked us, "When are they coming? What did your parents say?" We all looked at each other, aware that he couldn't address anyone in particular. He must've understood this, because he called out in his thin, groping voice, "What are your names?"
我们能听到他在下面走动。几分钟后他问我们：“他们什么时候来？你们的父母说了什么？”我们互相看了一眼，意识到他无法指定任何人。他一定明白了这一点，因为他用他那细弱、摸索的声音呼喊：“你们叫什么名字？”
No one answered until Aaron, who was the oldest, said, "My father said he's coming with the police, and he knows what to do." We admired Aaron very much for coming up with this on the spot. "Are they on their way?" The man in the well asked. We could hear that he was eating. "My father said, don't worry, because he's coming with the police."
没有人回答，直到最年长的亚伦说：“我父亲说他会带着警察来，他知道该怎么做。”我们非常钦佩亚伦能当场想出这个借口。“他们正在路上吗？”井里的男人问。我们能听到他在吃东西。“我父亲说，别担心，因为他会带着警察来。”
Little Jason came up next to Aaron and asked, "What's your name," because we still don't know what to call him. When we were talking among ourselves, he had simply become the man. He didn't answer, so Jason asked him how old he was, and then Grace came up too and asked him something, I don't remember. Finally, we all stopped talking, and we lay down on the cement.
小杰森凑到亚伦身边问：“你叫什么名字，”因为我们还是不知道该怎么称呼他。当我们私下交谈时，他仅仅被称为“那个人”。他没有回答，所以杰森问他多大岁数，然后格雷斯也走过来问了他什么，我不记得了。最后，我们都不说话了，躺在水泥地上。
It was a hot day, so after a while, Grace got up, and then little Jason, and another young boy, Robert, I think, and went to town to sit in the cool movie theater. That was what we did most afternoons back then. After an hour, everyone had left except Wendy and myself, and I was beginning to think that I would go, too.
那是一个炎热的日子，所以过了一会儿，格雷斯站了起来，然后小杰森和另一个年轻男孩——我想是罗伯特——去城里坐在凉爽的电影院里。那时候我们大多数下午都这么做。一小时后，除了温蒂和我，大家都离开了，我也开始考虑我也该走了。
He called up to us all of a sudden. "Are they coming now?" "Yes," Wendy said, looking at me, and I nodded my head. She sounded certain. "Aaron said his dad is almost here." As soon as she said it she was sorry, because she'd broken one of the rules. I could see it on her face, eyes filling with space as she moved back from the well. Now he had one of our names.
他突然向我们呼喊。“他们现在来了吗？”“是的，”温蒂看着我说，我也点了点头。她听起来很确定。“亚伦说他爸爸快到了。”她话一出口就后悔了，因为她打破了规则之一。我从她脸上能看出来，当她从井边移开时，她的眼睛充满了空间。现在他知道我们其中一个人的名字了。
She said, "They're going to come," to cover up the mistake. There it was, and there was nothing to do about it. The man in the well didn't say anything for a few minutes, then he surprised us again by asking, "Is it going to rain?" Wendy stood up and turned around, like she had done the other day. The sky was clear. "No," she said.
她说：“他们会来的，”以掩盖那个错误。事情就是这样，而且无法挽回。井里的男人几分钟没说话，然后他又问了一个让我们惊讶的问题：“会下雨吗？”温蒂站起来转身，像她前几天做的那样。天空很晴朗。“不会，”她说。
Then he asked again, "They're coming, you said, Aaron's dad?" And he shouted, "Right," so that we jumped and stood up and began running away, just as we had the day before. We could hear him shouting for a while, and we were afraid someone might hear. I thought that toward the end maybe he had said he was sorry, but I never asked Wendy what she thought he'd said.
然后他又问：“你们说他们正在路上，亚伦的爸爸？”他喊道：“对吧，”我们吓得跳起来，站着开始逃跑，就像前一天那样。我们能听到他大声呼喊了一会儿，我们害怕有人会听到。我想在最后他也许说了对不起，但我从没问过温蒂她认为他说了什么。
Everyone was there again on the following morning. It was all I could think about during supper the night before, and then the anticipation in the morning over breakfast. My mother was very upset with something at the time. I could hear her weeping at night in her room downstairs, and the stubborn murmur of my father. There was a feeling to those days, months, actually, that I can't describe without resorting to the man in the well, as if through a great whispering, like a gathering of clouds, or the long sound, the turbulent wreck of the ocean.
第二天早上大家又都到了。前一天晚饭时我满脑子想的都是这件事，还有早晨吃早餐时的那种期待。我母亲当时被某件事搞得很心烦。我能听到她在楼下卧室里哭泣，还有我父亲顽固的低语。那些天，实际上是几个月，有一种感觉，如果不诉诸井里的男人，我就无法描述，仿佛通过巨大的低语，像云的聚集，或漫长的声音，海洋汹涌的残骸。
At the well, we put together the things to eat we had smuggled out, but we hadn't even gotten them all in the bag when the voice of the man in the well soared out sharply, "They're on their way now." We stood very still so that he couldn't hear us, but I knew what was coming, and I couldn't do anything to soften or blur the words of the voice. "Aaron," he pronounced, and I had imagined him practicing that voice, all night long, and holding it in his mouth so that he wouldn't let it slip away in his sleep.
在井边，我们把私下带来的吃的放在一起，但我们还没来得及把它们全部放进袋子里，井里男人的声音就尖锐地高声喊道：“他们现在正在路上。”我们站得很不动，这样他就听不见我们，但我知道接下来会发生什么，我无法用任何东西来柔化或模糊这个声音。“亚伦，”他念叨着，我想象他整晚都在练习那个声音，把它含在嘴里，以免他在睡梦中溜走。
Aaron lost all the color in his face, and he looked at us with suspicion, as if we had somehow taken on a part of the man in the well. I didn't even glance at Wendy. We were both too embarrassed. Neither of us said anything. We were all quiet then. Arthur finished assembling the bag, and we could see his hand shaking as he dropped it into the well. We heard the man in the well moving around.
亚伦脸色惨白，他怀疑地看着我们，仿佛我们以某种方式承载了井里男人的部分。我甚至没看温蒂。我们都太尴尬了。我们俩谁也没说什么。那时大家都安静了。亚瑟完成了袋子的组装，我们能看到他的手在颤抖，当他把它扔进井里时。我们听到井里的男人在四处走动。
After 10 minutes or so, Grace called down to him, "What's your name?" But someone pulled her back from the well, and we became silent again. Today the question humiliated us with its simplicity. There was no sound for a while from the well, except for the cloth noises and the scraping the man in the well made as he moved around.
大约10分钟后，格雷斯向下喊道：“你叫什么名字？”但有人把她从井边拉了回来，我们再次陷入沉默。今天这个问题因为它的简单而羞辱了我们。井里有一段时间没有声音，除了井里男人移动时发出的布料声和摩擦声。
Then he called out, in a pleasant voice, "Aaron, what do you think my name is?" Aaron, who had been very still this whole time, looked around at all of us again. We knew he was afraid. His fingers were pulling with a separate life at the collar of his shirt, and maybe because she felt badly for him, Wendy answered instead. "Edgar." It sounded inane, but the man in the well answered. "No," the man said.
然后他用一种愉快的声音呼喊：“亚伦，你觉得我的名字是什么？”亚伦一直非常安静，此时又环顾我们所有人。我们知道他在害怕。他的手指在衬衫领子上无意识地拉扯着，也许是因为她为他感到难过，温蒂代为回答了。“埃德加。”这听起来很荒谬，但井里的男人回答了。“不，”男人说。
Little Jason called out, "David?" "No," the man in the well said. Then Aaron, who had been absolutely quiet, said, "Arthur," in a small, clear voice, and we all started. I could see Arthur was furious, but Aaron was older and bigger than he was, and nothing could be said or done without giving himself, his name, away. We knew the man in the well was listening for the changes in our breath, anything.
小杰森喊道：“大卫？”“不，”井里的男人说。然后一直绝对安静的亚伦，用一种细小、清晰的声音说：“亚瑟，”我们都吓了一跳。我能看出亚瑟很愤怒，但亚伦比他大，比他壮，如果不暴露自己、自己的名字，什么也做不了、什么也说不了。我们知道井里的男人在听我们呼吸的变化，任何东西。
Aaron didn't look at Arthur, or anyone, and then he began giving all of our names, one at a time. We all watched him, trembling, our faces the faces I'd seen pasted on the spectators in the freak tank when the circus had come to town. We were watching such a deformity take place before our eyes, and I remember the spasm of anger when he said my name, and felt the man in the well soak it up. Because the man in the well understood.
亚伦没有看亚瑟，也没看任何人，然后他开始一个接一个地说出我们所有人的名字。我们都颤抖着看着他，我们的脸就是马戏团来到城里时，我在畸形展示柜旁 spectators 脸上看到的那种脸。我们看着如此畸形的事情在我们眼前发生，我记得当他说出我的名字时，我心中爆发出的愤怒，并感觉到井里的男人吸收了它。因为井里的男人明白了。
The man in the well didn't say anything now. When Aaron was done, we all waited for the man in the well to speak up. I stood on one leg, then the other, and eventually I sat down. We had to wait for an hour, and today, no one wanted to leave to lie in the shade, or hide in the velvet movie seats. At last, the man in the well said, "All right, then, Arthur, what do you think I look like?" We heard him cough a couple of times, and then the sound like the smacking of lips.
井里的男人现在什么也没说。当亚伦说完后，我们都等着井里的男人说话。我先是一条腿站着，然后换另一条，最后坐了下来。我们不得不等了一个小时，今天，没有人想离开去树荫下休息，或躲在丝绒影院座位里。最后，井里的男人说：“好吧，那么，亚瑟，你觉得我长什么样？”我们听到他咳嗽了几下，然后是像砸嘴一样的声音。
Arthur, who was sitting on the ground with his chin propped on his fists, didn't say anything. How could he? I knew I couldn't answer myself if the man in the well called me by name. He called a few of us, and I watched the shudder move from face to face. Then he was quiet for a while. It was afternoon now, and the light was changing, withdrawing from the well. It was as if the well was filling up with earth.
亚瑟坐在地上，下巴抵在拳头上，什么也没说。他怎么能说呢？我知道如果井里的男人叫我的名字，我自己也无法回答。他叫了我们几个人的名字，我看着恐惧在每张脸上蔓延。然后他安静了一会儿。现在是下午了，光线在变，从井边撤离。仿佛井里正在填满泥土。
The man in the well moved around a bit, and then he called Jason. He asked, "How old do you think I am, Jason?" He didn't seem to care that no one would answer, or he seemed to expect that no one would. He said, "All right, what's my name?" He used everyone's name. He asked everyone. When he said my name, I felt the water clouding my eyes, and I wanted to throw stones, dirt, down the well to crush out his voice, but we couldn't do anything, none of us did, because then he would know.
井里的男人移动了一下，然后他叫了杰森。他问：“杰森，你觉得我多大年纪？”他似乎并不在意没有人回答，或者他似乎预期没有人会回答。他说：“好吧，我的名字是什么？”他用了每个人的名字。他问了每个人。当他说出我的名字时，我感觉到眼泪模糊了我的眼睛，我想把石头、泥土扔进井里，压碎他的声音，但我们什么也做不了，我们谁都没做，因为那样他就会知道。
In the evening, we could tell he was getting tired. He wasn't saying much, and seemed to have lost interest in us. Before we left that day, as we were rising quietly and looking at the dark shadows of the trees we had to move through to reach our homes, he said, "Why didn't you tell anyone?" He coughed. "Didn't you want to tell anyone?" Perhaps he heard the hesitation in our breaths, but he wasn't going to help us now.
傍晚时分，我们能看出他累了。他没怎么说话，似乎对我们失去了兴趣。那天我们离开之前，当我们静静地站起身，看着我们要穿过回家的树林的阴影时，他说：“你们为什么不告诉任何人？”他咳嗽了一声。“你们不想告诉任何人吗？”也许他听到了我们呼吸中的犹豫，但他现在不会帮助我们了。
It was almost night then, and we were spared the detail of having to see and read each other's faces. That night it rained, and I listened to the rain on the roof and my mother sobbing downstairs until I fell asleep. After that, we didn't play by the well anymore. Even when we were much older, we didn't go back. I will never go back.
那时几乎是夜晚了，我们免去了必须看和读对方脸色的细节。那天晚上，我听着屋顶上的雨声和我母亲在楼下啜泣，直到我睡着。在那之后，我们再也不在井边玩了。即使当我们大得多的时候，我们也没有回去。我永远不会回去。
Ira Sher's story, "The Man in the Well," was originally published in The Chicago Review. It was his first published story. Just in case there's any ambiguity about it, it's a work of fiction. Ira Sher's the author of the novel, Gentlemen of Space.
艾拉·谢尔的故事《井里的男人》，最初发表在《芝加哥评论》上。这是他发表的第一篇故事。以防万一有任何歧义，这是一部小说。艾拉·谢尔是小说《太空绅士》的作者。
Act three, Human Nature, The View from Kindergarten. One old approach to raising children takes as its premise the idea of that children are by nature little monsters, whose destructive and selfish impulses have to be controlled, with physical force, if necessary. And so far in our program, we've provided, I think, a fair amount of evidence to support this particular school of thought. We've heard so far about boys taunting other boys in a cruel sort of survival of the fittest, we've heard about children leaving a man to die in a well.
第三幕，人性，来自幼儿园的视角。一种养育孩子的古老方法，其前提是认为孩子天生就是小怪物，他们的破坏性和自私冲动必须受到控制，必要时使用武力。到目前为止，在我们的节目中，我认为我们已经提供了相当多的证据来支持这一特殊思想流派。我们听到了关于男孩们在残忍的优胜劣汰中嘲弄其他男孩的事，我们听到了关于孩子们留下一个男人在井里等死的事。
And so, for our final act, let's change things up a little bit. I want to tell you about an experiment done in a kindergarten classroom by a teacher named Vivian Paley, and it was an experiment to make children less cruel to each other. Paley is the author of many books about education, including one about this classroom experiment, and she's a MacArthur Genius Grant recipient, though she's embarrassed whenever anybody actually says that as part of her credentials. And until recently, she was a kindergarten teacher at the University of Chicago Lab School.
所以，在我们的最后一幕中，让我们稍微改变一下。我想告诉你们一位名叫薇薇安·佩利（Vivian Paley）的老师在幼儿园教室里所做的实验，这是一个让孩子们彼此之间不那么残忍的实验。佩利是许多教育书籍的作者，包括一本关于这个教室实验的书，她还是麦克阿瑟天才奖的获得者，尽管每当有人真正把这作为她的资历说出来时，她都会感到尴尬。直到最近，她一直是芝加哥大学实验学校的幼儿园老师。
And she got the idea for her experiment when one day, it occurred to her how often she heard children in her classroom tell each other no. No, there's no room here for you to play with us. No, I promised I would play the next 16 games with someone else. No, we're already playing, you can't join in. No, you cannot play with us. And it was the same children, always, who were made into the outcasts.
她产生这个实验的想法是在有一天，她意识到她在教室里听到孩子们互相说“不”的次数是多么频繁。“不，这里没有你的位置和我们一起玩。”“不，我答应了要和别人玩接下来的16场游戏。”“不，我们已经在玩了，你不能加入。”“不，你不能和我们一起玩。”而且总是同样的孩子成为被排斥者。
By kindergarten, Vivian Paley says, a ruling class starts to form among children. Certain kids notify others of their acceptability, and certain kids are told they're unacceptable, over, and over, and over again. And she points out that hitting and name calling are not allowed in school, but for some reason, this still is.
薇薇安·佩利说，到了幼儿园，儿童中就开始形成统治阶级。某些孩子通知其他人他们的可接受性，而某些孩子则一次又一次地被告知他们是不可接受的。她指出，学校里不允许打架和辱骂，但出于某种原因，这（种排斥）却被允许。
It's every day. It suddenly came to me that this hidden curriculum has taken over. It's almost as if we're teaching children for an elitist life of bosses. Of course, we weren't. We were trying our best to dissuade them. Often, you would put your foot down. Teachers do it all the time. "I'm going to have to insist that you let Johnny play." And before you knew it, the play area would empty.
每天都是这样。这突然让我想到，这种隐藏的课程已经接管了一切。这简直就像我们在为老板们培养精英生活一样。当然，我们并非如此。我们正在尽最大努力去劝阻他们。通常，你会采取强硬态度。老师们经常这样做。“我不得不坚持让你让约翰尼玩。”在你知道之前，游戏区就会空无一人。
The kids would stop playing?
孩子们会停止玩耍？
Yeah.
是的。
The cruelty of the children's behavior seemed clear enough. If adults went around telling each other, no, you cannot sit with us, no, we do not want you here, no, you have to go away, it would be clear that this is not the way to act. And so Vivian Paley proposed to her students that they have a new rule in the class. She wrote it up in front of the room. You can't say, you can't play. That is, if someone wants to join your game, you have to let them. And their initial reaction?
孩子们这种行为的残忍性似乎显而易见。如果成年人到处对彼此说，“不，你不能坐在这，”或者“不，我们不想要你在这里，”或者“不，你必须走开，”显而易见，这不是应有的行为。所以薇薇安·佩利向她的学生建议，班里订立一条新规则。她在房间前面写下了它。你不能说“你不能玩”。也就是说，如果有人想加入你的游戏，你必须让他们加入。他们最初的反应？
Disbelief. Both the ones who did the rejecting and the ones who were already used to being rejected could not see how such a plan could work. They understood the language. They understood what I was saying. But their amazement and distrust and fear that they would not be able to handle what it was that I was talking about, that play would be spoiled, was very apparent.
怀疑。无论是那些拒绝别人的孩子，还是那些已经习惯被拒绝的孩子，都看不出这样的计划怎么可能奏效。他们听懂了这种语言。他们听懂了我所说的话。但他们的惊奇、不信任，以及担心他们无法处理我所说的事情，担心游戏会被破坏，这是非常明显的。
Vivian Paley wasn't exactly sure what she should do, and so seeking some sort of input, she turned to the older children at the school where she taught. She visited all the grades from first grade through fifth grade and explained her proposed new rule, you can't say you can't play, and asked the children if they thought it was fair, and if they thought that it could work.
薇薇安·佩利不确定她应该怎么做，所以为了寻求某种反馈，她求助于她任教学校里年龄较大的孩子。她访问了从一年级到五年级的所有年级，解释了她提议的新规则——“你不能说‘你不能玩’”，并询问孩子们他们是否认为这是公平的，以及他们认为它是否可行。
And interestingly, what she ran into was a kind of pint size version of not in my backyard, not with me you don't. Third and fourth and fifth graders said the proposed rule might work with those kindergarten kids, because the kindergarten kids are nicer, and they're more willing to accept the rules from the teacher, but they said, kids their age, at their advanced age, were already way too mean with each other for this ever to catch hold.
有趣的是，她遇到了一种微缩版的“不要在我后院”心态，也就是“别和我玩”的那种。三、四、五年级的学生说，拟议的规则可能对幼儿园的孩子可行，因为幼儿园的孩子更友善，更愿意接受老师的规则，但他们说，像他们这个年纪的孩子，在他们那个成熟的年纪，已经彼此太刻薄了，这条规则永远无法奏效。
And they had a kind of nostalgia, even in third, and fourth, and fifth grade, a kind of nostalgia, and would talk wistfully about the days when they themselves were nicer, back in kindergarten.
他们有一种怀旧情绪，即使在三、四、五年级，也有种怀旧，会向往地谈论他们自己还更友善的日子，回到幼儿园的时候。
From grade to grade going up, they were more and more convinced of two things, that it couldn't work, it was against human nature, but they all seemed to feel that it could have gone differently at a younger age.
从一个年级到另一个年级，他们越来越确信两件事：它行不通，这违背人性，但他们似乎都觉得在更年轻的时候情况可能有所不同。
When children said that it didn't seem natural, a lot of the argument just came down to the whole point of play was that they want to play with their friends, that it's an extension of friendship.
当孩子们说这看起来不自然时，很多争论归结为玩耍的全部意义在于他们想和朋友一起玩，它是友谊的延伸。
Right.
对。
And let me ask you to read from the book. You recorded and then transcribed the conversations you had with the children about this. Let me ask you to read to the bottom of page 19.
请允许我请你读读这本书。你记录并转录了你与孩子们关于这个话题的对话。请你读到第19页的底部。
Right, this is one of the first formal discussions we have on the issue of you can't say you can't play. And this Angelo, who is about to speak, is certainly one of those who is-- not only feels himself, but is-- often rejected.
好的，这是我们就“你不能说‘你不能玩’”这一议题进行的首次正式讨论之一。这个安吉洛（Angelo），即将要发言的人，无疑是那些——不仅他自己感觉，而且确实是——经常被拒绝的人之一。
Angelo, "Let anybody play if someone asks."
安吉洛：“如果有人要求，就让任何人玩。”
Lisa, "But then what's the whole point of playing?"
丽莎：“但那玩耍的全部意义是什么呢？”
Nelson, "You just want Cynthia."
尼尔森：“你只是想要辛西娅。”
Lisa, "I could play alone. Why can't Clara play alone?"
丽莎：“我可以一个人玩。为什么克拉拉不能一个人玩？”
Clara was one of the other children who was often rejected.
克拉拉是经常被拒绝的另一个孩子。
Often rejected, and goes and sits in her cubby.
经常被拒绝，然后去坐在她的小隔间里。
Right.
对。
Angelo, "I think that's pretty sad. People that is alone, they has water in their eyes."
安吉洛：“我觉得那挺难过的。独自一人的人，他们的眼睛里有水。”
Lisa, "I'm more said if someone comes that I don't want to play with."
丽莎：“如果有人来，而我不想和他玩，我更难过。”
Teacher, "Who is sadder? The one who isn't allowed to play, or the one who has to play with someone he or she doesn't want to play with?"
老师：“谁更难过？是被允许玩的那个人，还是不得不和一个他不想一起玩的人玩的那个人？”
Clara, "It's more sadder if you can't play."
克拉拉：“如果你不能玩，那更难过。”
Lisa, "The other one's the same sadder."
丽莎：“另外一种也是同样的难过。”
Angelo, "It has to be Clara, because she puts herself away in her cubby, and Lisa can still play every time."
安吉洛：“那肯定是克拉拉，因为她把自己关在小隔间里，而丽莎每次都能玩。”
Lisa, "I can't play every time if I'm sad."
丽莎：“如果我难过，我就不能每次都玩。”
One of the children you talk about a lot in the book is this girl who you call Lisa, and when you put the rule into effect the first day, Lisa, you say, she pouts, "It's not fair at all. I thought we were only just talking about it."
你在书中谈论很多的其中一个孩子就是这个你称之为丽莎的女孩，当你第一天实施这个规则时，丽莎，你说，她噘着嘴说：“这根本不公平。我以为我们只是在讨论它。”
Right
对。
"I just want my own friends. What if someone isn't nice and hits me?" And then the discussion, you say, "Well, you know we have a rule about hitting." And then Lisa's not impressed with this, and she says, "There's some people I don't like." And there's this really amazing moment where Angelo says, you write here, Angelo says without emotion, "You don't like me." And everyone looks at him as if acknowledging the sad truth of his statement.
“我只想有我自己的朋友。如果有人不好，打我怎么办？”然后讨论中，你说：“好吧，你知道我们有一条关于打架的规则。”然后丽莎对这个不以为然，她说：“有些人我不喜欢。”然后发生了一个真正令人惊叹的时刻，安吉洛说——你这里写道，安吉洛毫无感情地说：“你不喜欢我。”每个人都看着他，仿佛承认了他那句陈述中悲伤的事实。
Yes.
是的。
What happened once the rule kicked in? How much did you see Lisa resist? I mean, what finally happened?
规则生效后发生了什么？你看到丽莎抵触了多少？我是说，最终发生了什么？
Within a week it was as if this had always been the way life would be. And she was-- it was a tremendous event for Lisa. And if I may add parenthetically, it's not in the book, but all the years later, whenever Lisa, the child I call Lisa, met me in the hallway, she would always stop and ask me how is the rule doing, and give me an example of something she had done that showed she was still trying to follow the rule.
在一周内，生活仿佛一直就是这样。而且她——这对丽莎来说是一件大事。如果我能在括号里补充一下，书中没有写，但多年以后，每当丽莎——那个我称之为丽莎的孩子——在走廊遇到我时，她总会停下来问我规则执行得怎么样，并给我一个例子，说明她做了一些事，证明她还在努力遵守规则。
The last time I met her was in the grocery store with her mother, and she said, "Mrs. Paley, it's still pretty hard for me, but I know I can do it, and I always try." And her mother nodded, and said, "She really does, you know."
我最后一次见到她是在和她母亲一起在杂货店，她说：“佩利太太，这对我也还是挺难的，但我知道我能做到，而且我一直在尝试。”她母亲点了点头，说：“她真的在尝试，你知道的。”
Vivian Paley. Back when her class was debating the new rule, she wondered, can you really legislate this type of morality? Can you order people to be kind to each other, not to exclude others? "Is there not," she wrote, "a natural desire to include certain people and exclude others?"
薇薇安·佩利。回到她的班级在辩论新规则时，她想过，你能真的立法规定这种道德吗？你能命令人们彼此友善，不要排斥他人吗？“难道没有，”她写道，“一种包容某些人而排斥其他人的自然欲望吗？”
And, she says, that once I put the new rule into effect, there was a palpable sense of relief in her class, as if they'd been rescued from meanness. The children were grateful for a structure that let them feel good about themselves and each other. Her book, You Can't Say You Can't Play, is published by Harvard University Press.
她说，一旦她实施了新规则，班里有一种明显的解脱感，仿佛他们从刻薄中得到了拯救。孩子们很感激有一种结构让他们对自己和彼此感觉良好。她的书，《你不能说“你不能玩”》，由哈佛大学出版社出版。
Yeah, let's go. Our program was produced today by Nancy Updike and myself, with Peter Clowney, Alix Spiegel, and Dolores Wilbur. This is our production manager Todd Bachmann's last week on the program. He's actually been our production manager since we've had a production manager, years and years. So much about our radio show, and the fact that our computers run, the fact that we actually have network computers, the fact that or contributors get promptly paid, to the existence of our online store, are thanks to him. It's going to be very hard to work around here without him. That we wish him the best.
好的，走吧。我们今天的节目由南希·厄普代克和我制作，彼得·克劳尼、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔和多洛雷斯·威尔伯协助。这是我们的制作经理托德·巴赫曼在节目中的最后一周。事实上，自从我们有了制作经理以来，他一直就是我们的制作经理，已经很多很多年了。关于我们广播节目的很多事情，事实上我们的电脑运行，事实上我们确实有网络计算机，事实上我们的撰稿人能及时收到报酬，到我们在线商店的存在，都要归功于他。没有他，在这里工作将非常困难。我们祝愿他一切顺利。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. Our website, www.thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to our programs for absolutely free, or buy CDs of them, or, Todd asked me to say this, we just started selling the DVD of the cartoon slide show about Louis Sullivan and his architecture that I did with Chris Ware. That's www.thisamericanlife.org.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。我们的网站是www.thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以绝对免费地收听我们的节目，或购买CD，或者——托德让我说这个——我们刚刚开始销售我和克里斯·韦尔一起制作的关于路易斯·沙利文及其建筑的卡通幻灯片DVD。网址是www.thisamericanlife.org。
You know, you can download today's program in our archives at audible.com/thisamericanlife.
你知道，你可以在audible.com/thisamericanlife的档案中下载今天的节目。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金赞助信息]
WBEZ management oversight for our program by Mr. Torey Malatia, who I met this way.
WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责，我是通过这种方式认识他的。
What started off as name calling soon escalated to a series of mock angry slaps.
起初的辱骂很快升级为一系列假装愤怒的掌掴。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周再见，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio, International.
PRI，公共广播，国际。